all right another Tim Burton movie
starring Johnny Depp is here we go
dark shadows dark shadows is the story
of Barnabas the vampire played by Johnny
Depp wasn't always a vampire he was a
dude then he got cursed by Eva green
who's a witch he gets buried for a
couple hundred years that he gets dug up
in the 1970s now he's here not here here
in the 1970s all right when I was going
into this movie I was like all right
there's another Johnny Depp Tim Burton
movie which means is gonna be Jack
Sparrow with a different coat of paint
now washed it in too much credit Johnny
Depp doesn't act like Jack Sparrow in
this movie he acts weird and eccentric
and it's a bummer that he's not gonna
ever play normal roles ever again
they'll always play weirdos but he
wasn't Jack Sparrow there were enjoyable
scenes there were a lot of times I was
like oh yes that's good I'm having a
good time
other times I was like that's completely
stupid why is it dead stuff it has quite
a few moments of that contrast and the
bummer is the contrast is so big you go
from like enjoying the movie to hating
it and you're like why does it have to
be that way why can't I just enjoy the
movie or at least kind of enjoy the
movie consistently speaking of contrast
the movie set up to be a comedy like it
or not that's just what this movie comes
across as being sowing seeds for Johnny
Depp like slaughters a bunch of people
around a campfire you're like oh it's
out of the blue and it was a bit much
that works for Lost Boys doesn't quite
work for this movie I mean everyone in
the movie did a good job I like Jackie
Earle Haley is the drunk guy I'm not
even sure what his role in the movie was
like a lawn keeper he was drunk Eva
Green is the witch although sometimes
Eva Green comes across as like an over
actor in this movie and I think it's
because she was trying to hide her
accent she looked great though hot chick
I think in order to get accurate
perspective as to what Dark Shadows is
actually like imagine you just watched
the trailer - Dark Shadows and Johnny
Depp wasn't in the movie like imagine
he's just not in the movie Barnabas the
vampire has been played by someone else
yeah the movie would look like some
dopey goofy Addams Family ripoff piece
of that you have no interest in
zing so really Johnny Depp's the only
real pull in this movie I do enjoy pop
culture humor so I like the fact that
he's a 200 year old vampire alive in the
70s so you know the culture and
technology is gonna freak him out he's
gonna be like what is this devilry
witchcraft it's a sign for a store or
something it's just funny but the
enjoyment of that kind of just wears off
really soon you're like okay now it's
just kind of dopey some enjoyable scene
some not so enjoyable seeing some funny
scenes some dumb scenes some scenes that
turn Barnabas the loveable vampire to a
murderous in the end
shadows is okay but you're not gonna
remember it at t-minus one day yep
already forgot in the end its Tim Burton
it's weird I'm gonna use a phrase that
like critics and people you I don't like
using this phrase but his movies are
really indulgent really you watch his
movies and it's almost like he's waving
his hands in front of a camera like I'm
Tim Burton quirky and dark that's me I
just rather watch a good movie not Tim
Burton's finger paintings with Johnny
Depp starring in them however this movie
does teach you everything you need to
know about women which is given the
opportunity they will probably curse you
lynch mob you and bury you in the ground
for a couple hundred years and that's if
they love you so your favorite vampire
now this is certainly vampire movie but
vampire character what is it who is he
who she comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more